the nation's top health officials
testifying remotely today before the
Senate on reopening the economy dr.
Anthony pouchy issuing a warning about
States restarting their economies too
soon and if some areas city-states or
what-have-you
jump over those various checkpoints and
prematurely open up without having the
capability of being able to respond
effectively and efficiently my concern
is that we will start to see little
spikes that might turn into outbreaks
and there was this contentious moment
between Senator Rand Paul and doctor
foul chief take a look I think we ought
to have a little bit of humility in our
belief that we know what's best for the
economy and as much as I respect you dr.
Falchi I don't think you're the end-all
I don't think you're the one person that
gets to make a decision I have never
made myself out to be the end-all and
only voice of this I'm a scientist a
physician and a public health official I
give advice according to the best
scientific evidence there are a number
of other people who come into that and
give advice that are more related to the
things that you spoke about about the
need to get the country back open again
and economically I don't give advice
about economic things I don't get advice
about anything other than public health
all right Greg what did you take away
from this hearing today well I always
say you know I've said this before if
you put our pointing fingers there's an
entrance fee you know you have to ask
you have to say how would you have done
this differently but you cannot use
20/20 hindsight we do know that Trump
relied on experts and experts were wrong
on masks tests ventilators and
especially the experts that were
informing Cuomo rest homes so if you
believe that you would have done better
the big question if you were if you knew
something why did you hold out on us all
you smartypants people in the media why
did you have this insight virus inside
info on fighting a virus and held it
back for us
and that it is amazingly it's amazing
how accurate pundits and politicians are
when they're looking backward for it
like the standard for testing you know
tell us exactly what the standard for
testing is considering experts don't
even know what that is because they
haven't dealt with it before so the
thing is you can't tell what a good job
is when it's the first job we know it
could always be better but you don't
know how so do not trust the media on
this but do not fault people whether it
is foul Chi whether it is Trump even
whether it is Cuomo who give advice or
take a risk and turn out to be wrong
because everybody's gonna be wrong on
this no matter what and Jesse one thing
I did notice the day in the hearing is
that the Democrats were very frustrated
at the government and that the Trump
administration in particular and their
solutions though seem to be that we need
more government yeah because
government's done so well over the last
so many years to Greg's point about the
Democrats strategy it's a great point
because we still don't know what the
Democrats strategy is because all they
say is Trump is either doing things too
slowly or he's doing things too quickly
so all it is is just a complaint
I mean Petraeus had the surge strategy
you know Trump had the Tariff strategy
which China there is no Democrat
strategy on this it's whining that's all
it is so I watch this entire hearing and
it's incredibly frustrating because
they've set these traps with tests now
we would have gotten a test sooner if
China hadn't destroyed the virus samples
in the lab if they had just shared it
with the rest of the world we get a
gotten the test a lot quicker but now
here's what they do with testing now
that we've tested more people than all
the other countries in the world
combined they say okay well the testing
rate isn't good enough permission to
make a sports analogy Dana this is like
when a quarterback goes 9 for 10 for a
hundred yards and the opposing
quarterback goes 39 for 50 for 400 yards
the Democrats think the quarterback that
went 9 for 10 is better because he had a
better completion percentage know
anybody with
brain they'll take the quarterback they
had 39 completions for 400 yards so
don't fall into that trap I do agree
though testing needs to get better and I
was disappointed with the CDC director
this guy Redfield I don't get a good
feeling about him they had the lab
contamination early he doesn't inspire
confidence he's a poor communicator he's
not clear he doesn't look charged up
something about this guy I don't like I
can't put my finger on it but the fact
that he hasn't been out in front and
center on this whole thing from the
beginning as the CDC director tells you
a lot but he has been I mean like the
White House has been having him do a lot
of talk radio all across the nation
because they think he's been great but I
take your point and of course it wasn't
easy one to hear everybody during the
remote there was the dog that was
barking and also Lamar Alexander's cute
dog that was sitting behind him what did
you take away from the hearing dogs well
I find that entertaining because I think
it's very real and you get the sense
that these are human beings you know we
see them in the official setting of a
Senate hearing room and you can think
I'll is just some guy in a suit in
response to what jesse was saying by the
way I was taken by the idea that you had
Republicans like Lamar Alexander MIT
Romney saying hey the testing has just
not been sufficient and nothing to
celebrate and especially if we're
looking towards reopening schools in the
fall we don't have that in place pouchy
was very clear about that we don't have
any kind of rigid regimen or testing or
any kind of way that we could assure the
Chancellor the University of Tennessee
for example I think that's what they
were talking about with senator
Alexander that you can open school in
the fall because right now it just
doesn't seem that that's a reasonable
goal to have the other thing I would say
is when in terms of what faoud she said
again I don't think this is Republican
or Democrat I think thought she just
said with those with the potential for
spikes out across our country not just
in the big cities there's just too much
potential for death and more suffering
and more people getting sick and I think
it was very clear to me that he was
trying to not
politicize it not to get into a
back-and-forth with Rand Paul but to say
he was speaking as a scientist and that
people should listen yeah Katie on this
school thing the chairman did go back to
Maui and say let's clarify in fact you
said different solutions for different
places but he also said something that
people might take some hope from and
that was that when pressed by Senator
Romney do you really think it's
realistic to get a vaccine within a year
or two foul she said absolutely that is
possible yeah and I thought what brand
Paul said about keeping kids out of
school for a year and the consequences
of that especially if they're
lower-income kids there would be severe
consequences for that and also doctor
foul Qi said that the vast majority of
people who get this disease recover and
I think there needs to be more focus on
the recovery numbers in addition to the
new cases and the continuation of the
flattening of the curve and in the end
there are going to be consequences on
both sides of this no matter what
decision they make if you keep it locked
down there'll be severe consequences in
so many different sectors for that if
you open it back up yes there will be
more cases but the deal was never to
have zero cases that the deal was to get
the hospital's ready to deal with this
yeah there's no perfect decision to be
made indeed